so our next speaker has only been in
america for about 12 months
and she spent three of those months and
i want to make sure you get the
direction correct
going from the west coast to the east
coast
on amtrak
in 2021
so i want everyone to think about
what that was like because i know this
is sort of this romantic ideal and i
want to hear if she was in sleeper cars
or regular seats like how much is just
like oh going from one city to next and
waiting a week or spending overnight in
sleeper cars so i'm really interested in
seeing how that all went because there's
a sort of like romanticism about riding
the the train across country
so
everyone please welcome
surabhi
hello everyone thank you so much for
having me here today my name is
and i'm going to be talking about
uh best practices for the governance of
digital public goods these are primarily
research findings from a research report
that i worked on housed at the ash
center the harvard kennedy school and
supported by the rockefeller foundation
so very excited to dive in and take you
through this
to the through the preliminary findings
of our report
um to start with i'd like to acknowledge
that i'm here on behalf of a fantastic
team
led by lecturer at the kennedy school
david eaves
some of you might know him and also my
colleagues leonie and omayra who could
not be joining us today but have given
me this responsibility to introduce our
report to you all
so
um what are we talking about today
we're talking about digital public goods
i don't know if you've heard of the term
or not but
digital public goods are um
essentially categorized as free and um
are categorized as such when they are
freely and openly available with minimal
restrictions on how they can be adapted
distributed and reused so they're
essentially
public goods but for the digital space
that's how we're thinking about them now
there's one thing that makes digital
public goods incredibly different from
public goods that we know of in
economics and otherwise which is that
term that i've highlighted the minimal
restrictions so when dpgs that's how we
call them as we go about in this talk
um
they voluntarily agree to restrictions
restrictions on who makes decisions on
the development roadmap what the
requirements are on the membership fee
membership criteria all of this to me
ensure that there is a commonality and
uh between the sort of reuse that that
can be brought as well as to ensure that
costs have come down just to give you a
quick example i wanted to uh introduce
my favorite dpg which is the x road in
estonia an integrated infrastructure
that allows for data sharing between
estonia finland iceland and is governed
by the nordic institute for
interoperability solutions this is a dpg
that we have referenced throughout our
report and really is in some ways a
guiding dpg for for a lot of research
now going forward um
why did we choose to spend 12 months of
our time thinking about digital public
goods governance
like i mentioned when digital public
goods are come together or digital
public goods exist they do so through
minimal restrictions these restrictions
are important for the very existence of
a digital public good because they
ensure that it's both restricted as well
as coordinated in such a way that the
digital public code doesn't splinter
into different
bespoke solutions instead it is the
governance in itself that allows for
this coordination and then thus the
restriction i know it's a lot maybe to
follow for people who are not in
this part of the you know not thinking
about this world but stay with me as we
go forward
um
we decide this is why we focused on
governance and we felt that a digital
public good without governance is indeed
not a digital public good at all
gov just picking up code uh public
sector code throwing it on github does
not necessarily make it open it does not
necessarily make it additional public
good
um and that's where we feel that
governance comes in to set certain norms
standards to ensure that additional
public good really lives up to its
public good part
um governance we think is time consuming
governments we think is hard of course
that there are
these constraints the risks however
especially on on emergent and small
digital public goods is high and
therefore we think that governance is
indeed essential
you might be wondering why am i talking
about something in a digital public good
lingo when all of this seems so much
similar to open source
um after all additional public goods are
open source
uh products they have that is a
requirement as for the definition that
has been set by the digital public good
alliance based on the un report that we
um that we have referenced but what
differentiates digital public goods from
open source solutions
four things that we have recognized one
is that intentionality os projects are
often
born in in a very organic manner think
linux think all your big sort of open
source
um communities whereas dpgs are
more definitely more mature relatively
more mature and intentional and defined
equity a big concern for anybody working
in the government space
um os projects don't necessarily have
this as a focus but um and often uh open
source projects can lead to under
representation of certain groups because
it might it's not intentional whereas
the government needs to always keep in
mind equity concerns
um sustainability again because of the
nature of open source projects they have
uh different sustainability uh or are
often very unclear sustainability uh
models whereas with
additional public goods it is a big
criteria sustainability is a big
criteria
in terms of
capacity again
not everybody is
not every government is equipped to
attract as well as retain developers
as large corporations or organic open
source projects can do which is why we
differentiate
digital public goods from open source
and have spent this much time sort of
focusing on um this very niche category
of uh public good studies
that is emerging in the world
so
coming back to governance where does
governance fit there's all of these
other facets to a digital public good
that could have been studied i told you
why we focused in on the governance
module and
however i want to recognize that
policies thinking about funding
especially funding assessment
capabilities all of these are all
incredible uh parts that we do hope that
others conduct research on and i and i
could also reference a few others who
have conducted research on the same
issues
what do we mean by governance um
the key decisions
around governance who makes the
decisions and who decides who makes the
decisions this i think is is the crux of
what we've been trying to figure out as
well as the development of the road map
how is it done
this is what we will refer to as
strategy as we go forward of course
there are other peripheral decisions as
well who can participate in developing
maintaining the dpg and
given that it's an open source
inherently open source sort of product
how do you enforce community norms and
rules these this is how we're defining
what governance is in this entire uh
spectrum
what did we do essentially this was the
fun part of
my grad school life for the last 12
months
spent a good amount of time reading
literature on governance and open source
for somebody who's has no technical
background and and you know has to go
through all that jargon it was a lot of
fun to do
but learned a lot through this
literature review and we focused it on
governance in os like i said um
conducted more incredible interviews
with leading experts who guided our
recommendation and
um with existing leaders in the digital
public good space
this was um conducted across
different time zones in the world thanks
to zoom
unlim we did have two limiting factors
though
and that is um that there was only a
small number of tpgs which have robust
governance structures nice as i
mentioned is is is one of those the
nordic institute of entropal pda
solutions
um and of course
as anybody in the public sector would
attest to the visibility and access to
governance failures so we really didn't
know whether some you know when
something goes wrong nobody wants to
talk about it especially in government
um so visibility and access to
government uh access to government's
failures was definitely for
poor
um
which is those were our limiting factors
i want to very quickly um
run through the two frameworks that we
used that
one is a much more strategic triangle
born here at the harvard kennedy school
essentially that focuses on
balancing three different angles or
three different important considerations
legitimately legitimacy and support
public value and operational capability
to create any sort of net uh public
value this is a this is a framework that
we have used
in this in in our analysis and some of
you might be aware of this this is simon
wadley's maturity mapping uh where we've
we have taken different epgs which have
different goals and levels of maturity
and and sort of map them in this in this
spectrum of whether they're from
experimental to um you know standardized
infrastructure so bespoke solutions and
product in between
um
yeah so those were the two frameworks
that we used it's uh academic reports so
we made sure to uh reference these
frameworks throughout our work
now i will very quickly sort of um
jump into our
recommendations and sort of take you
through this for the next 10 minutes so
the first the first um
and
my slides are yeah okay um so the first
recommendation or we like to call it a
playbook because after all you know you
don't necessarily want to
give out a bunch of
bunch of to-do's that
um dpgs that have very varying goals in
context as well as different sort of um
intentions to
um say that this is exactly what you
want to follow so we've been flexible in
what we have said is
is is observed across different dbgs
emerging ddgs as well as mature dbgs and
here's something that you could be doing
here something you could try
um so the first first two however are um
finding a vision and mission value
statement as well as drafting a code of
conduct we have recommended to everyone
it seems very you know it seems very
basic at least that's how i thought
about it when when you were thinking
through that any any sort of
organization any product coming together
would be would sit down and think
through finding a mission vision value
statement but
it was important to sort of say that
this is a requirement for a dpg to think
through um and and i think expecting
this in the public sector is is really
holding um the organization to a higher
standard already so let me just dive
into um the first of our recommendation
what it allows as you all know it's you
know a vision mission mvp statement
allows for
the purpose and the objectives to be
clearly articulated and and therefore
through the articulation it allows for
it to shape strategic decision-making
um and our guidance here is that really
invest in a well-defined mvv as a
starting point because this will allow
for
dpgs to think about
what the government's design should be
centered on and how it maximizes public
value
on the right hand side you'll see that
this is applicable to all of the um all
sort of levels of maturity of the tpgs
and it maximizes public value in the
more strategic triangle
going forward drafting a code of conduct
again several open source communities
have uh we've heard case studies you
know cert stories essentially about how
managing contributive behavior who leads
who makes decisions what sort of norms
should be followed has been a cause of
concern and
um
which is why we we recommend as a best
practice to um come up with a code of
conduct for contributors
and really sort of put this out in the
open so that everybody's on the same
page with respect to this
code of conduct
the third recommendation that we have
had is the crux of you know what what
we've been trying to work on which is
how do you design governance bodies i
know there's a lot of technical folks in
this conference and of course it's
called the our conference and and often
what happens is that you know this might
be an afterthought
but
through our report and to us through
this particular recommendation in fact
we've tried to bring the focus on how
governance designing government's bodies
is essentially not should not be an
afterthought and institutionalizing you
know authority and accountability for
decisions especially for digital public
goods which which are intentional which
start at the uh with a very with a lot
of um with a lot of maturity sometimes
um ensure ensuring that they have a
governance design you know they design
their governance from the start is
incredibly important and the one thing
that we felt really works or rather
we've
observed in in our research that works
is
uh which is an emerging best practice is
that separating the strategy and the
technology implementation and allocating
different sort of decision rights and
responsibility to each
has been
has been something that we've we've seen
ensures a better sort of governance
design the strategy board would be
focused on road map and community uh
wide decisions whereas a technology
board would be focused on you know code
and managing that and day-to-day
operations so this is this is a this is
our
third recommendation
very quickly going forward
an important concern especially with
respect to our equity value is that
we've observed a lot of dilemma in what
happens when decision making culture
becomes very
unanimous uh stakehold and and also when
what happens when in the eeg scales so
for when additional public good skills
we've noticed that stakeholders that
control this strategy board essentially
control the direction of the dpg while
we're not making a recommendation or a
guidance in this specific case we are
saying that this is something that dpgs
should be cognizant about
um and this the second and third
observation that we saw was that
uh unanimous decision making and a lack
of sort of have taking all stakeholders
together
um the guidance that we're putting forth
is that of course designed for plurality
and uplifting voices uh very
intentionally from resource-constrained
stakeholders
um
and and the last and final
recommendation that our playbook part
that we've had is
um this fantastic
uh
you know part about open source is that
it allows for contributions and
therefore we've noticed amongst existing
dpgs that there are
um three types of contributors voluntary
contributors contributors who are either
paid by an external entity or paid for
by members of the community and dpgs can
engage these external contributors
through um multiple three three types
essentially uh formalized without any
sort of formalized structure without uh
or with a formalized structure that has
contribution mechanism but also a third
type which is um which my slides are
heating up for some reason but a
formalized um
structure which has a governance
consideration as well of course the
third one is something that we would
recommend but
at the least we would say that it's
essential to have formalized
contribution mechanisms and not stick
with the
um lack of any any such thing
um i have no idea how i'm doing on time
but i would like to thank you all for
uh
listening to our talk i really hope that
this my talk i really hope that this was
informative and like i mentioned these
are preliminary data findings uh
research findings and we will be
publishing this report in the next few
months i hope to share it with the our
conference community uh in the meanwhile
please feel free to reach out to me my
email id is just my first name and last
name at
hks.harvard.edu and i'm on twitter as
well
um
very open to uh hearing your thoughts
this is a very niche subject that we've
just picked up on and we're very excited
to uh you know publish it and take it
forward and also hear all your feedback
so thank you so much for this
opportunity and thank you for listening